boulet cab show we have got a special
guest who's is this the yeezy jacket it
is
that is interesting
is it comfortable
yeah it looks like it's like um
i don't know
just it looks like a sleeping bag yeah
sleeping bag vibes i mean it's very
apple how there's no zipper
no
there's nose nothing
are there pockets there are pockets here
oh thank god
hassan is here barely welcome
awesome people who don't know you work
with that you're are you signing the
dame dash are you work you're working
with dame yeah just you know like
the rockefeller dream man like that was
my you know as a kid to be signed or
like get the co-sign from dane that was
like everything so
yeah well listen you're the first person
that we had come do a freestyle and
brought uh mpc
so what does this mean perfect that
means we're in new territory i love it
um
yeah no i just
you know this is something that i'm
working on for the new album okay so i
figured
you know kind of you're gonna play
the beat off of the mpc are you gonna
make what are we doing here yeah i'm
just gonna kind of
like trigger stuff and just i'll tell
you what we're just going to let you do
it how about that
all right that way that's how that works
huh yeah why even explain it when you're
about to [ __ ] do it uh for people who
don't know what you're ig with your
social media all that good [ __ ] yeah
hassan thank god go follow yeah uh shout
out to dame shout out to dame dash
studios doing big [ __ ] over there man um
salute to him uh and uh his movement but
yeah let's let's just get to it yeah
poppington you know that's dame you know
so i had you got the popular whole
ceo shorts yeah yep all right so um
yeah this is uh this is basically right
now it's called anything is possible
it's the vibe okay
we're gonna start it with dame actually
my [ __ ] hassan made this beat
god and the devil look at us like a coin
toss heaven and hella separated by a
loincloth
i used to pray at night never thought
i'd get to heaven was afraid of heights
and i've been sending god i need a
church mosque and synagogue
man i've been sinning god i need a
church mars and synagogue be still and
know i'm here perfect love casts out all
fear love is not emotion love is not a
feeling love is forgiven true healing
hallelujah they bump this to shibuya
japanese denim masato with the mula i'm
the ruler the new slick rick hassan
thank god it's more than a pick
follow this you ain't gotta be a friend
of me with this love i even love my
enemy the only one speaking truth public
enemy with rap so chuck d it's like a
memory top villain restore the feeling
and if you have anger you're a murderer
killing humans judge vices god judge the
heart
overcome the world
that partner
now we got perfect peace
everything we ever need
kill the ego before it kills me
let the true me be free
all thoughts are lies man it's in your
head
seven deadly sends you to walking dead
purify fly like a dove the absence of
hate love l stands for all the lost ones
oh [ __ ] she played you son and v
stands for you know what an e for
running out of gas on me love love love
love
me me me me
that's what she said i mean that's what
i said that i go deflecting again again
i close my eyes and i do it for the
ancestors now that's the true meaning of
apply pressure god on the keys makes the
band better only love if the skin tone
is sand desert you know pyramid perfect
nothing lesser never drink spirits cause
the spirits are known ouija board flow
they just hit you with a drone frequency
alignment i do it for the home and i've
been seeing visions it's chilling to the
bone bad red bone and she take me to the
dome think i'm indeed dawg i can't let
it alone
in the city of the prince purple rain
i'ma just go deep in her minnetonka lake
she gon make me get my gucci's wet
i'ma make her leave the movie set
we gon make each other's mood again
you hula hooping with a hool again yeah
i bet i tell the truth again
they play us out in budapest
i be feeling like the golden child
not now that's before a while i'm a real
fly multi-game list i got no game just
some [ __ ] understand this smiling ass
cheek to cheek you famous she said highs
beat to beat you dangerous ha
sun is blazing ha
sun is blazing ha
sun is blazing ha
sun is blazing
boulet kev is amazing
look mama we made it
rockefeller it's the family tree dame
said jay yeah now me shout out nipis
like he wrote the new new testament from
la to london lawrence heaven saying
there it is
heaven said
the second coming this a preview
yay gonna hear this and be like
yo
i need this for donda too
and we gonna hit dame like what we gonna
say
my big brother was biggs brother used to
be jay and biggs brother still yay's
brother who said house play that again
watch the throne two let the story begin
begin my [ __ ] hassan made this [ __ ] my
[ __ ] hassan made this beat my [ __ ]
hassan made this beat
there it is
that was not at the end of that that was
yo man so you make all your beats too uh
yes sir that's dope yes sir
but i've been working for the new album
i've been i just sent um rook from
justice league yep yep a bunch of stuff
um
because i'm like yo you know they from
tampa too of course i'm like yeah i used
to drive by y'all studio and be like if
y'all just you know they used to have an
artist uh named prime that was from
tampa yeah prime and then what was the
other dude from tampa that was popping
for a little bit
[ __ ]
oh uh blog era
yeah
he was like a he's like a plies vibe no
no no
[ __ ] i forget the guy's name but shout
out to tampa but yeah you're from saint
pete yeah like yep saint pete ming yup
chapter 727 shout out to [ __ ]
salem's man i miss them i miss them
gyros you know what i mean shout out to
ahmad odd socks that's my guy that's my
brother too man odd socks is the gang
you already know what it is they
represent uh uh us very well we
represent them shout out to lrg too
because they're our sponsor for the
freestyle series yeah
we have a wooden giraffe [ __ ]
anyway one more time shout out to ig
yeah hassan thank god
um you know dame dash uh desco
poppington you know he'd be posting me
and stuff so follow both of us and you
know catch the vibes there it is boom
the album is called the second coming is
it out or is it it's not out no
it's coming
it's coming and
it's coming with a tv show so dame dash
has dash studios and he just did a deal
with fox soul right so my show that i
created it's called no offense
um
it's starring me and dame right and it's
kind of like an entourage meets you know
seinfeld kind of vibe fire and so the
show is going to premiere
um the the album and the show are both
premiering in february that's big so
next month yeah so the songs the songs
are gonna like each episode will be like
a song song so you'll have like a that's
that's dope i think you showed me a clip
of one of the things yeah dame walking
dane walking into the glass window
i i was sort of responsible for that
moment yeah no i was dope i saw you you
played me i think it was uh he was like
you were you were there and they were
like dame was running late to the
interview yeah so yeah i kind of made
some of it up but
that's from that's going to be a part of
the show what you showed me yeah yeah
dope yep no offense and uh the show's
called no offense the show is called no
offense and it's
is definitely you know
in this climate right now of cancer
culture and everything people going to
be mad about this show good i can't wait
because we making fun of
everything everything and everybody as
you should you know so
it's kosher's trash anyways
thank you for coming through brother yes
thank you brother boom hey i know you
just watched the crazy freestyle
appreciate you watching make sure you
subscribe and make sure
you show some love to our folks at lrg
clothing man listen
i've been [ __ ] with lrg since i was
in high school and they are still doing
their [ __ ] thing all right and i got
something special for you 30 off your
next order at lrg all you got to do is
use the keyword and by keyword i mean
promo code
use the promo code kev30 that's
kev30 we're gonna put the website right
there you see it right there
l dash r dash g
dot com all right we'll put the website
right there cook put the website right
there
save you 30 off one more time use that
promo code kev 30 on lrg's website for
your chance well not your chance you'll
actually get 30 off it's not like it's a
[ __ ] contest just use the code and
you got it all right shout out to lrg